okay let's do it thank you gentlemen
welcome back to your favorite quarantine
[Music]
once again we back at it and I got a
special guest on today a little outside
the comedy community it's not a podcast
guys not a guy you've seen on many other
podcast
tyshee an actor he's been on the TV show
taken spit on Vikings you've been on
this new show called council valve on
ABC welcome mystic yes yes yes names mr.
Clive stand-in and are really glad to
have them on
yeah yeah so anyways yeah this is like a
new a new person it's like a you know
he's really a great he's a British actor
is fantastic he's been on a lot of great
stuff man
so I'm just glad to have him on the
podcast right now and hope you guys are
enjoying all these episodes during
quarantine and once again make sure if
you want to watch me game you can watch
me Erik Griffin game and I've been
playing a lot of war zone with people
I've been playing with bobbi and Steve
Lee you know what I've been just been
playing Fifa band playing a lot of
different things but mostly wars also
checked it out at Erik Griffin gaming on
twitch and YouTube but anyways I'm
really excited to have this guy on the
podcast his name is Clive stand-in again
he's on this great show on NBC called
Council of dads that we talked about
that Allah we talk about his movie
career but talk about being you know in
the United States as a British actor and
it's a little a host of other
interesting topics so I really
appreciate you guys tuning in to rhythm
with Griffin every week and here's
another great episode with mr. Clive
Stanton and I hope you enjoy gentlemen
welcome to the program mr. Clive
stand-in you know you wonder my first
guest that I don't know at all you know
just so you know but it's still very
interesting and then like you're British
which I didn't know either you know
every des but that's like I have so many
questions about that before we get into
all the other stuff especially Council
of dads which is a great show by the way
I watched it with my girlfriend last
night and she was bawling okay so
invested in every character and just
crying her eyes out from like you know
the last like 35 minutes of this show is
just it's just really emotional
television but you're British
and is it the dream to come to the
United States to be a part of Hollywood
or is it the fact that the British
system is like two episodes as a whole
season and it's not like economical like
if they had 15 season episodes in over
there would you have come to the United
States to be an actor or was there
always your dream to come the United
States I think it
so is the the roles and the characters
and in the American marketplace this was
so much more television than it always
has been we am we only have five
channels in England and only two of them
make really really good drum means a BBC
and channel for you know an ITV but
that's it so you know like you said
there's the six bar dramas there's four
part dramas you never get a 13-episode
drama let alone 22 episodes so the
others that that drive but it's just and
I think I don't like to admit it but now
I've been on both ends of the spectrum
but you know the money that you can put
behind a TV sometimes makes it so much
better I mean there's many so much great
scripts and great acting can go when you
know you're leaving Charm School you get
the chance to kind of be in some amazing
big-budget epic drama like Vikings Game
of Thrones a list of things it kind of
is every dream come true in terms of
kind of being able to play let's pretend
on a massive scale so I suppose get that
as well the American German system we
don't there's any lately the
co-productions have been coming around
for calendar and England's where we've
had the money to actually make these big
epic Joe Anderson yeah I you know I know
what you're saying cuz I've been
enjoying some of these like Netflix like
action movies that they come out with
right now I don't necessarily like the
story sometimes but there's so much
money in it and the amount of production
value would like the action sequences
you kind of go wow this is actually
enjoyable to watch so I guess I see what
you're saying that is important like you
have this and then you have this balance
between like doing something that's very
entertaining and doing something that's
very artsy and I gotta tell I could tell
you have like a there's both there's
part of you that wants to always be in
like something like Hamlet or like you
want to be but it's kind of known for
being you know the budget only goes so
far and we have rickety sets and kind of
men in costumes and things and you can
go with it's a family drama so I kind of
did that and you see that that's a very
very successful show in Britain but then
I remember we joined Vikings season one
we didn't have a lot of the budget to
the show and then we have
we'd have just half of a the bare bones
of a Viking marketplace in the
background of studio by season five and
season six we pretty much had the set
was the size of a theme park you know
could be viking world and utah to work
and they put you in the costumes which
are incredible in themselves and you
walk onto set and you're like you've
been taken back in time so that's what I
mean it's just incredible but you just
add attention to detail and the
specificity involved you need to have
that lump sum money ready to put behind
that to have that detail whereas on
Doctor Who is just as much fun to go to
work and and play around with aliens and
monsters and things but you we never had
that kind of you know that experience
you'd always have to kind of like you
know beg Boren's feel and kind of twist
your imagination loyal but to kind of
make it work and film in tiny look
pockets of warehouses and things make
them look like spaceships and that you
have like I feel like you're like what I
like about your look for instance is
that you're in between being like the
cool best friend but at the same time
being like taken you know being like the
action lead what do you prefer
I mean do you want to be like you know
the the stay-at-home the dad on a show
or like the the you know the the lead
doctor on the Grey's Anatomy or
something or or or do you like this like
jump running and jumping and slashing
and shooting which one that which one do
you draw is you more I it's always about
it's always about character really I do
love action I've always been a very
physical person I mean what I was since
I've been young I've just been so sorry
my body too I was my first job when I
was 13 14 years old was working a stunt
team as show at forestry enacting the
tales of Robin Hood and things so be my
most kids were getting their first
paperboy job or working in a retail shop
or something like that on a Saturday
house upstate that trees and jousting so
I suppose it's always been with me but
but it's always about character at the
end the day because I was so stoked I
Kings is an action show it's got battles
and bloodthirsty action and things but
it is just another family and it's it
and if you give a script and you can
relate to the character and actually
explore something about humanity and
that's what draws me usually I always
think that a lot of these shows like
Vikings game of Thrones of The Walking
Dead
those kind kind of almost bleak
post-apocalyptic or kind of like history
shows that kind of in a in another world
they usually exploring humanity going
back to their baser instincts where it's
kill or be killed or going to survival
of the fittest and and that's something
that you can explore as a character and
as a human
whereas Council of dads that I'm doing
now is almost exploring what humanity
does when it comes together when we're
here for each other and what we can
build together and and that's it still
comes from character that's what draws
me nurse so it's not necessarily action
at all it's about spending as many
plates as I can and I've learned
something when I was a lot younger a
Drama School when it was about know you
can act if you play your cards right as
an act you can act until you die I mean
as long as there are 90 year old human
beings in the world that can be 90 year
old actors you know it's about having
that longevity what what gets taken away
from you if you get pigeonholed your
typecast so if you want to work until
you're at ninth and you've got to keep
reminding people that you're more than
just a one-trick pony you've got to kind
of go look I can spin this plate I can
spin back so what I've tried to be doing
you know when I have Vikings which is a
steady successful job but one for six
seasons you start thinking about what
you can do in the off time I've got
three months before season one and
season two and I've got time to pick one
job in let's not play you know Viking
werewolf seven you know whatever it is
film that gets offered your way let's
try and show people you could do
something completely different my
players 55 year old drunken alcoholic in
the 30s and this film called inline
flare Knights a couple years ago I did
this funcle' revolt which is now
trending on Amazon has just been
released on Amazon which is the second
show you can it's a heist drama and
playing this 1970s kind of crazy guy
from Rhode Island accent and everything
I just like to do that I like to just
try and keep showing people I can do so
on any winnette when anyone ever turns
around and goes what about clive stands
for that [ __ ] what the viking guy is
like ah but have you seen him in this
you know it's just I think that's what
you have to do if you want to kind of
keep doing what your loves for as long
as possible
man I told you preaching to the choir I
totally understand what you're saying
because like when my career started I'm
a comic I'm a funny guy I was in a show
workaholics there was like I was this
crazy character and then like after that
to break out of that was so hard it was
like always like being sent for comedy
comedy and then I got on this Showtime
show which I had to like you know be
dramatic and it was like so rewarding
and now you know now I'm like I'll be
considered for other things so you do
get pigeonholed yeah but I hate but I
hear from you like you do sound like an
artsy guy you very much you enjoy the
art of acting and and and that part of
it and I feel like is that what you
consider before you take any role yeah
definitely I am I can say was quite a
lot but it's the truth I got into acting
to draw attention away from myself
rather towards myself I get a bit scared
when I started you know I'm not a method
actor in any way I like to just act I
like to create a character this
completely far removed from me and and
that's the challenge when I was a drama
school I went to lamda for three years
and you know what we were taught there
is it's kind of like celestial let's
pretend which is a really stupid way of
saying just you're lying for a living so
don't get caught yeah and it's about
pretending to be somebody else and
that's what draws me to it about how
much I can invest and learn a new craft
and and invest in it so much that people
will believe that I am that person
rather than having to walk around and be
that person you know like my dog has
died my dog is dead and trying to pull
your own emotions and this doesn't
interest me at all so I mean that's
where it really comes from the art of
actually yeah awesome yeah so you're not
like a Daniel day-lewis type guy
not at all not at all kids kids I think
I started being a parent when I was 22
years old so after I have to love that
character up leave them at the door and
come get down and teach the kids at the
moment homeschooled I have to play with
the kids and because I can't bring my
characters home I'm you know it would
just be a car crash that's interesting I
like that you feel that way so that that
means it sounds to me like it comes
natural to you I think that it was
something when you started doing it you
realize oh I love this I can do it it's
a place you could draw on things very
easily do you feel that way about
yourself becomes everything I mean
that's the thing it's the first thing
you think about the last thing you think
about when you go to bed it really does
want to take on a role
I saw it first nice to do start to
become that character because I look
everywhere for research for yes it's
just copying people and you know people
watching and you just taking
everything's this is kind of another
thing that charm school it's like
there's so many different ways of acting
that you can only take what you can for
your toolkit no you can't you can't and
that's the difference between the
training I think from being British and
go into dramas for three years and then
some of the American actors I know out
here they have one acting coach and if
the acting coach works for you you and
your laughing is incredible because if
their way of teaching works for you then
you've got the great acting coach
unfortunately just because someone's a
great acting coach it doesn't
necessarily mean that their way of
teaching is gonna work to you as an
actor it's like trying for a circle you
know shape into a square hole it really
doesn't I'm wearing when you're a drama
school you have 20 or 30 teachers that
come through the doors over the three
years and they all teach you different
stuff but I got taught how to emulate
animals and become animals that might
help you never work for me I've never
used alby's work in my work it's all hey
relax yeah it's the most to capture I
played the principal I'm an alien vs.
predator I used that kind of like piece
of art and Panther is half gorilla and
Rhoni use the annenberg playing predator
but you know the point being is you take
what works for you from all these
different teachers and then you
conveniently forget what it doesn't you
know make a big thing of it you just
create your own tool box so when you
come out you've got your own way of
acting so there is no right or wrong of
acting and I think that's that's kind of
where I come from oh that's a good
attitude to have so then that means that
you know you don't necessarily come on a
set with a bunch of Americans and just
think to yourself all these untrained
imbeciles are gonna you seem to have a
good as good attitude about it
you know and they can I can I go well my
acting coach and I go three times a week
and so it's probably and they used to
teach Brad Pitt and you're like yeah but
they probably work for Brad Pitt their
teachers working for you you've got to
get out there and feel realize what it
is that makes you act you can't just
emulate someone and copy somebody
because that's it's bad acting
do you like when you go get a part
here in the States do you do you often
look at it if and want it to be like
your British in the part is there a part
of that when you see that you go or you
see then you go always from Boston and
you say yourself is that like one of the
hardest things about like working here
is that you have to think okay now Who
am I where am i from now I got to do
that all the time is it second nature
for you to or is it hard but I mean it's
funny you think about it I have actually
played a bridge so long it makes it
reminds me of them when I apply for my
old one visa yeah you have to get a visa
to work in America Paris it's described
as an alien with an extraordinary
ability and as lack so it's very whiz by
what how do you prove you have an
extraordinary ability and and it what it
comes down to you and your British on
the forum is you can play you can play
Americans better than Americans that's
good it comes down to I have informed it
gives me a stamp in my passport staring
coming to America because I complained
Americans better than Americans I can
tell you like for me like sometimes I
used to I used to bug me and always bug
me when I would find out later like like
it's like Walking Dead like you
mentioned before the guy that plays Rick
Grimes
he's like British or something or I
think he's British and when I heard him
in the interview and it blew my mind I
was like what isn't this like the guy
that was playing Superman he's from
Australia this guy from this guy you
know so it's like it's like a thing so
you're you know it's almost like do you
guys have like a club oh yes and we were
welcomed with us then the Australian
started coming over the Australians do
it but they had the sexy surf bodies too
and we were like oh so there was like a
Australians allow your on our patch
these damn Australians are taking our
jobs let's talk about Council the dads
you know I like I said I I watched it
and I was very the pilot but I get it
I'm sure that the rest of the show is
not going to be as heavy as the pilot
you know and it can't be because it
would just be too much but I get why
they had to set it up like that but it
is very it's a very touching show you
know and I can see the potential for a
lot of great great dramatic moments
great character development and great
family moments and so is that what drew
you to it and what do you have to say
about the project like what do you it
has to be that we have to set the
premise of the Council of dads which we
have to cast Tom Everest god is
incredible actor that would draw people
in and be this brilliant dad that we all
have to stand up to and emulate and and
it is full of grief and it's about
losing someone but this fear is at least
that this season for the first couple of
episodes is to fall out of what happens
but it's it's mainly a healing show it's
about joy it's about finding joy and
humor and and who turns up to support
you in times of grief and things and so
it's actually already uplifting show but
you have to start it in a place to build
from just becomes flim-flam and cheesy
sentimental BS it has to be a place of
reality which is this woman has lost the
love of her life and served these
children and these men are coming on who
each have aspects of the lost father and
the lost husband and when you kind of
almost pieced them together you get him
back again his values and his legacy and
everything he stood for but it's gonna
have trials and tribulations along the
way these are three men who are kind of
like the Stonehenge for the family they
don't actually kind of gel very well
together they're very different
personalities so you kind of have to you
know drama is built from conflict so you
have to start with some kind of conflict
for it to kind of branch out somewhat
and then you start to see this family
come together in gel like the modern
family that
was lit by now I mean TV for many years
has created a well for a while it was a
real family but I think it's quite a
fake family now where it's just mom dad
and aunts and uncles and grandma and the
kids and this is about who shows up this
is this reminds me of my kind of family
where I sometimes see my aunts and
uncles 5-6 times sorry once every 5 or 6
times a year or less or sometimes it's
every 6 years but my friends turn up and
they're part of my family my kids took
my friends and and when I grew up I had
my great oh I had my uncle Steve EP and
I always thought uncle Steve he's just
my dad's best mate nobody at all but he
was right there and he showed up when we
needed him you know and my mum's crying
my dad wasn't there he was there he was
there to take me play football you know
that kind of thing we think that's where
this shows going the council dad's is
about who shows up and it's about icily
a bit everyone being inclusive and being
together and I think it kind of small
yeah it's a good watch you know because
I mean I mean fine if I'm just being
real that's being honest I don't 100
about it I mean at first you know if the
at first glance you go okay here's
another show like you said that's
sentimental
it's just like this and there's a lot of
shows a day kiss you know coming off the
heels of just like us you know I mean
it's like or what's that whatever that
show is this is us yeah just like this
is a documentary I was in but this is us
it's like they go oh that works people
want to see that people want to see
families people want to see drama people
want to see people dealing with things
but at first glance I saw their selves
like oh here we go
multiracial you know it's like you know
here's oh there's a this kind of kid oh
there's the gay black guy there's the
bump and then like you know sort of
first 20 minutes you're watching and I'm
like I hope this isn't but then I was
like oh man it really gets you in
because it really is a lot of really
great performances and they did
jam-packed the pilot with a lot yeah
this is the truth because that annoys me
too in the pilot because I signed on to
do this script and the script is
incredible and I came to me and it read
like a movie and it was because this man
is ill and the problem it's not a
problem but it is what it is network TV
has to fill in so many commercials but
our first cut of the pilot came in
something like 72 minutes
incredible it was one of the best
version it could be but then you have to
cut out all those little bits that don't
push the story on in order to get the
commercial breaks in thing so it has to
be about 40 years a 42 minutes 44
minutes I think the show is and that's
the thing so it does run really quickly
but because of the formula we had to
have Scott died in the first episode
because that be not what the show is so
we had to cut it and you know I show run
a Tony and Joan a husband and wife they
based they described as killing your
babies they have to just kill babies in
that scripts because they were brilliant
scenes that you told you so much about
the characters look the wood then they
have to rewrite them for absolute two
three four so you will see those moments
but unfortunately everything had to get
truncated into that first episode and
that's why it runs so quickly so much
information and I do a double episode
but that's not the way NBC or any
network works they won't do like a
special 70 minute episode I know very
special Council of dads yeah you know
yeah I agree I know what you're saying
it's it's a lot it sucks when they have
to do that but I think they gonna did a
good job I mean like I said I'm actually
gonna watch the show like I watched it
because you were gonna come on my
podcast
you know and I and then when I first I
was like oh god please let just be good
because what am I gonna talk about with
this guy about to chef you know I mean
but then I watched I was like oh man
this is great like I say my girl was
just you just bawling watching it so I
mean it I mean it is a good watch you
know and it's weird that you do have
like a balance where something becomes
too melodramatic or something becomes
too like whatever's going on it because
I find that an American television
it's very copycat you know so it's like
if there's a if there's a oh it's a
family family drama show is working
you're gonna see six of them yeah if
there's a medical show that's working
here comes all the medical shows and
there's you know see what might be
original I mean I don't watch too much
network TV but I just I took this job
because I loved the script myself and I
didn't really watch that much if this is
us my kids loved it and I've grown to
love this is artists because what I love
about it is that at the end of every
episode there's so many issues and
subjects that are brought up and that
the kids actually ask me questions and
therefore it becomes something
around rather than work around the water
cooler it becomes a round sofa with the
kids since like what is what was Vietnam
what it was wasted veteran what is PS
PTSD and you can talk about it with your
kids in a kid-friendly way are you
educating and I think we do that because
there's a lot that comes up as you just
mentioned there's a lot of issues that
come up their current issues but I think
what is original about it as opposed to
something like this is us and million
little things this I think we have a lot
of humor and cats with that and you'll
see it it's about finding grief through
humor which i think is very real you
know when you podcasting today which is
a really scaling up my dad jokes and it
was a dad joke about you know the dad
says what is this and the kid goes out
unknown he goes neither derive her here
it comes again
yeah you laugh because it's a dude rush
the PM life is like when you can't laugh
when things are so bad you have to laugh
this is nothing else to do so when
you're grieving of your dead husband
your grieving or whatever then sometimes
you do find yourself making the most
bizarre humor out of the worst situation
and I think with that happens a lot and
counseled with that so you find this
comedy after darkest situation when you
find joy and I think there's not many of
those shows that do that those shows
taken vows very seriously within reason
you know it's very serious I think we a
little bit if we were to take anything
that I think belongs to counsels about
is that humor for we don't take
ourselves too seriously um by doing that
I think it's more realistic but you
actually have these moments when you
when someone asks you for the time how
you feeling
whenever you find yourself humor and
bizarre you know just truths that you
just and you're looking at I could be
the same person in that situation yeah I
know what you're saying and that that's
you know cuz even my own from my own
personal life are you know I'm a
stand-up comedian and when I first was
thinking about doing and starting I
worked at a school and and then this
really popular kid
tragically was killed you know and he
had and they had a funeral and when kids
die there's more people at a funeral for
kids cuz they they touch so many more
lives you know what I mean the older a
person is the less people are at the
funeral unless there's somebody so
prolific and famous you know what I mean
but for the most part it becomes like
you know less people there get less
people know this but anyways I I had to
speak for the kid I had to like do the
eulogy and I'm in this church and I'm
I'm telling myself don't cry like let me
be strong for all the kids that are
watching cuz they had they even had like
kids in the church and kids in the
gymnasium
watching this funeral you know and I'm
just like don't cry and I'm not even
listening to what's going on except um
so don't cry and then the priest they
put on Ave Maria okay
Ave Maria comes on and not just Niagara
Falls I'm just crying and then the
priest goes Erik so I had to go up and I
and I'm I had to talk about this kid you
know and I found myself being humorous
about it
I found myself in the midst of this you
know I remember saying you know I see a
lot of his ex-girlfriend's here cuz he
was a ladies man kid too and I was like
he's gonna be in trouble he's probably
doing and people started to laugh and I
started to laugh and then it was like I
was like oh man look at this morbid
crazy situation where a child is dead
and we're finding a way to laugh and I
think that is human that is real that is
like how we really are in situations the
stages of grief and and I do think
Council of dads hits on that very well
yeah and I think that's what you'll find
as the season goes on there'll be
moments of tears and you'll definitely
cry it'll be sad but there will be
moments where you find stuff crying just
because it's so beautiful and so lovely
and you'll be crying lobster
but that's what it's designed to do do
you find yourself um do you pick parts
now bait because you're like your father
you have like how many say you have
three kids
yes so you had a point in your current
hour you're like you're not just gonna
do anything is there a part of you that
goes this character has to be a certain
way because I don't want to be seen this
way for my kids is that a part of your
thought process great question it really
is I always think about that for a long
time that when my kids were really young
I used to get some chip from past agents
and things for it as well
massive opportunity it's a horror film
you get a fortune because it's a horror
film and then they don't cost very much
to make but they make millions at the
box office and your name will get bigger
because you were in this film that gross
100 million dollars and I go yeah but I
get changed all in half with a chainsaw
and my brains come out everywhere and I
really don't want my children to see
that that's it decision done yeah I read
20 pages not into it yeah formulated
into a more yeah I think I have a the
greatest works of Clive Stan you might
need you have the complete works of
William Shakespeare the complete works
of Clive Stan right yeah let me think
about DVDs I mean no it was all Apple TV
and stuff now but I used to imagine all
the DVDs on a shelf be a list yeah and
those things I took because I enjoyed
the experience that didn't come out the
way I want it but I don't want my kids
to be ashamed of anything I did buy the
characters I played I mean there was
something I see read quite recently I
was in Vikings and bikers very violent
things but I have I have a line with
gratuity I think there's too much of it
on TV right now and I'd actually don't
think Vikings wise I think was very
cleverly filmed in a way where you
didn't actually see a lot of the end of
the gratuitous moments as opposed to
some other stuff in Game of Thrones but
there was one I read the day I was
really into it and I was lying there
loved the character and then there was
just a moment where the character there
was actually wasn't the character I was
up for it was a character who was in the
show came out the back seat of her of a
pickup truck and bludgeoned some a woman
to death with a hammer but the way they
described in the script made it very
clear that they wanted to have the blood
come
the windows and head caved in and that's
not interested I don't want to put any
more of that out into the world
especially what's going on right now and
so yeah so I suppose that's it my kids
do that make my kids do kind of
influenced me a lot but even in Council
of dads may not be my kids but just what
was going on in my life as you're
interested but I I got I got offered a
lead in another TV show but I won name
because it's a nice telling now because
I didn't end up doing it but um and it
was very different big action kind of
lost type kind of show and and it really
can be intrigued me on that sound I was
the lead and I'm like wow this could be
good for my career and it's a good job
and be exciting and then Castle doubts
has came out of nowhere for me my
manager just rang me and I was on the
way taking my Jeep into the to the the
workshop to have it serviced and it was
pouring down with rain in LA and and I
was on the way and he said like I'm just
sending you a script can you read it
school counselor dad so that was covered
yeah I'm kind of doing the car thing I
really couldn't oh you've gotta read it
what are you gonna do back because the
writers are leaving town at 2:00 in the
afternoon they really want to meet you
and this is Leonardo juice reversers
yeah so I said yeah I hadn't heard
anything about it so I got an uber home
left my cut makar in the workshop all
day and got an uber home I was soaking
wet and I sat down at the computer and
20 pages in I was crying
um and I rang my manager on 20 pages and
I said I'll take the meeting I haven't
finished it yet but I'm gonna take the
meeting I wanna meet them but it's
because I knew that they wanted me to
play Anthony which is the best mate of
Scott who dies of cancer but good and I
was like yeah but I want to go in there
and talk to them I think talk to my
manager brother so I was in my head on
the way to the meeting I was like what
talked about playing Scott because I'm
the data throughout the three he says
data file and I'm really relate to this
and it's a brilliant story and made me
cry
I don't play Scott so I got to the
meeting I started kind of pitching
myself for Scott and Tony in general you
know he dies in episode 1 yeah I know
but I just think that's what I can give
more to you know I think I can give you
something special with that guy's
character
Gertrude but I was I was scared because
my best friend in in real life who's the
best man at my wedding 'he's been
there's with my oldest friend he's been
there for me
all throughout my life he was dying of
cancer he had colon and he wasn't
looking good at the time and I just
couldn't see myself I love the character
that I play in the show and I was just
worried about playing because like I
said earlier I didn't really want it to
life to any other in my own life and I
thought where as if those emotions take
over and and I told them that I said
kind of nearly cried in the meeting I
said like this is a brilliant script I'm
just not sure I can play Anthony because
of my circumstances right now and Joan
said I think maybe this is probably why
you have to play this role I was just
gonna say they probably loved that I
mean I I hate to say it but the moment
you said that cuz even now you're like I
feel your emotions even right now I feel
it man and so if I was the producer of
the show
I'd be like I'd be like oh my god we
gotta get this guy to play this
character we talk about crying when you
watch I was reading his scripts and I
was crying and usually it's it's empathy
you find empathy with the character
you've never even met made-up character
and somehow you find yourself cry
because you just feel sorry for that
person's feel for that person but
sometimes because you see yourself in
someone on screen and there's what was
happening to me unless it really
emotionally connected with me and and
some of the episodes filming there was a
couple of scenes where I can't mention
which axis it was because it might give
away the plot as people are watching it
but there were certain actors that I'd
have to go after we finished filming I'd
be like I need to have a stiff drink and
you just sit down and let it go which is
holding on to some stuff not just about
that about other things yeah I could
imagine really done that with the job I
had days where you've gone whole that
was emotionally draining but not days
when you're like you'll let me a body go
and you're going I'm not sure if I can
calm down from this this is this is
Clive if that's kind of lens you know
this is acting anymore and it was a bit
it was a bit frustrating to kind of get
was frustrating to give it to everyone
else cuz you've got you know countries
of crew watching you and everyone and
you feel like the whole life is
imploding in front of people on that go
it's great but you know speaking of that
on those same lines I often say this is
not natural like being an actor like it
is not natural it's actually not good
for your body your mind your soul all
the time it's because of what your
saying right now like when I hear about
like the late Heath Ledger you know
coming off a project and being like oh
man like depressed and like whatever it
is I totally get it like what we're
doing to ourselves to achieve those
moments where people go oh my god that
was great it's not always it's not
always the best of thing how do you
manage those feelings but then again I
agree with you but then the devil's
advocate says but this kind of some kind
of therapy in it - yes yeah like it's
hard for me to talk about I want to talk
about it but and it's not because I
don't want to talk about with you is
because I know that I'll give away a
massive plot spoiler and counselor - but
I'll do that that's what makes it huh
but there was there were certain things
where I I just I had put in a kind of a
closet for years and or swept under the
carpet and thought I was dealing with
and then when you start approaching it
from the script and you realize that
it's kind of makes you realize you're
not the only one that's gone through
this and it's so well observed and you
colorfully so I was venting as well you
get it out what did comedies like that -
like when I go on stage and I'm
formulating a joke about something
personal in my life that is a form of me
like working it out so I guess in this
situation with this show you got lucky
because you you you have a script that
is kind of close to you have an
experience in your own life that mirrors
this in the show but what I'm saying is
sometimes what if it wasn't like that
and you know it's somebody that has to
get to where you are that's the part
where it could be like oh man this is a
lot cuz I did a dramatic scene in the
show that I was in that I was like when
it was done I was like ah man like I
hope they don't have like reshoot sir
you don't I mean like you just sometimes
you you a part you do a scene you do
mind you just want to go I'm done with
that like let's hope we never have to do
that again but this feels like a show
that's like gonna be challenging you all
the time oh yeah we digging deep like
you know you're ready for it obviously
oh you wouldn't have taken apart but
like are you really ready for it yeah
and I think um more so for our lead
Sarah Wayne Callies because she I think
about it in terms of let the reader
because what's so nice about it is
requesting this ensemble so when you go
to the read-through we never had tissues
at the wreath ruse put it that way
nearly everybody would be bawling and
every episode for whatever reason and
you but this is a lot yeah well lucky
enough cuz you're an ensemble you go
that's the bit I have to do that's the
bit they have to do that's little bit
they have to do we bring it all together
and you've got a brilliant show but the
lynchpin that connects most of those
things is her so like oh every others
he's gonna be in this but you know what
you know you're making me think of
something though okay so as an actor
when you get us a script of the episode
you know cuz I've done this I get the
script and I realize when I'm reading it
at first I'm reading it as a fan like
I'm reading it as like what it's gonna
look like and I've been brought to tears
you but by reading something I'm like oh
man that's so great
but but then I think about the person in
the scene they're not actually
experiencing that know you know so then
sometimes it's not as because not as bad
if it's making sense of what I'm saying
you know what I mean yeah you're reading
it is like oh this is what the emotion
that you're gonna feel when you see it
but then you might be somebody in that
scene it's not acting like that at all
you might be being an [ __ ] or you
might be you know you know being that
being the the sounding board for someone
else in the scene that inspires those
emotions so I get why you guys are
crying because this show like it's so
much yeah well I hope it comes on what
is it come on it comes on this day so
our proper slot is Thursday nights of a
p.m. this Thursday which is coming on
it's gonna be on because they have a
special Parks and Recreation special so
that's gonna be on an 8 now and we're
gonna be the first episodes at 9 and we
gonna have a double episode except so 2
goes on at 10:00 Oh what you know I'm
not sure if this will come out to mark
this particular episode so you know guys
you could go back because it's on Hulu
also cuz I watched it on Hulu so I think
NBC shows are on Hulu so cuz I never
know when things come on anymore because
I DVR everything and then watch
everything on Hulu and Netflix so then
there's so when things come on I go oh
that's on or it just shows up on my TV
but it's definitely a must watch us on
NBC it's called Council of dads so you
guys got to watch that but you know
before we go I just wanted to ask you
like you know put all that stuff behind
it's like what are you watching
like I know you got I know when you have
kids you you don't have time to like get
into that deep show that you'll because
you have you're busy watching Elmo and
whatever else Taylor Swift videos but
like what like what are you watching
when you have time to yourself
what are your shows and movies that
you're like do you watching right now
well what's interesting from my oldest
son 17 and he's just said to me even dad
have you heard of this show called
Breaking Bad I'm like yes I love it
because I've seen all of the episodes
it's been quite nice I've been watching
them again with him perfect excuse to
what's a brilliant show again and you
see oh yeah but for me when I'm on my
own in the evenings when they're in bed
I like succession I think it's
incredible so mother Cheryl I get blown
away by the actor Jeremy strong I've
never heard of them before succession
and I just think he's incredible I think
which one is he which one is he
Kendyl the yes yes because I every
episode is such a I mean an actor
appreciating an actor is such a fine
line that every episode you either you
feel sorry for him the next MC do you
hate him then you can love him together
and he keeps you on that type row every
episode which must be so tough to play
that fine line yeah going backwards and
forwards that delight in the dark side
and his relationship with his dad it's
just but that's the crux of it that's
what I love about the show and you just
said it perfectly like I love a
character that makes me hate them and
then and then pity them and they feel
sorry for them and then you just go oh
come on man don't do that like if you're
watching a show and you said yourself
why did you do that that's just like a
perfect performance my fee McFadden's it
was a lovely lovely man in real life his
character that husband to [ __ ] I mean
he's just the wedding you feel sorry for
him
I think and then you want him to he had
that moment where he stood up to the
senator dad you know and you had that
moment you like finally grow some balls
and I I know what you're saying that is
really fantastic show but you know what
you made me well I have another question
for you though speaking of a show like
that it's such a great show you can get
lost in it but because you're an actor
and because you're such an artsy
pretentious actor too by the way and I
mean that with all sincerity I mean in a
good way can you get lost in a show
still or you always have that moment of
life I love that choice I got really bad
I got a job speak you just analyze
everything you know like something
you're liking it because you're
analyzing the actor that you love and
you're trying to figure out how if you
can see his choices and yeah I remember
when I went to the the Odeon cinema
which is the biggest in what we have in
London in Leicester Square and I see
Moulin Rouge with my mum I remember was
the first film in ages where I just sat
and watched it hit me it just reminded
me of that but no I do now I tend to
kind of relax a little bit more but I'm
good but I also I'm a sucker for
punishment cuz I don't like something
you know some people are just very good
as gum right I'm gonna walk out to them
or I'm just gonna turn it off yeah I
find myself getting stuck watching it
till the end because probably because
the pretentious act in me what warning
will meet someone one day you'll go it's
my favorite thing to go no it's not
because of it you always get that that
guy or girl who goes us because you
didn't watch until the end it was really
with you with that I do I find myself
doing the same thing and it's
interesting what you said about watching
Moulin Rouge because what that is is
what that's what the words guilty
pleasure even me ask is that you watch
something that you could that someone
might consider bad so you can get lost
in it yeah I think that as an actor you
need that because I find myself there's
no middle ground
so something's fantastic like succession
I am looking at this going
oh man that must have been great
to film or I'm going like Oh what great
choices
oh I'm talking and improvise Wow between
that the two sons of the daughter some
of that stuff is not scripted it's tears
that three great actors who get along so
well here if off each other and I said I
got oh and when did the scenes stop and
when did they start improvising and what
do they keep that crying I know exactly
what you mean but what but then the
other side of that isn't when
something's bad I find myself becoming
such a critic but like this like I'll
see you scene and I'll go oh man I must
have been a terrible shoot day cuz I
start you ever do this you ever start
counting shots you start to go oh god
there's a setup
oh god four setups for that scene yeah
and I find myself getting lost in that
and I'm not even enjoying it anymore or
like terrible lighting or I'm like oh
why they make that choice or like why'd
they do that or that didn't make any
sense and then I'm not even but then
part of me the pretentious person in me
I enjoy that the people that get
obsessed with continuity because my wife
belies both about it it winds me up when
someone somethings brilliant and you're
good it's brilliant no I yeah based I
was in a different place Lori's hair was
moved and you're like so you know what
programmers me but you know what I do
okay I take a step further when I see
that in my mind it triggers that was the
best shot yes I go I go I go the reason
why they had it cuz I go they know his
tie was long ago the notes his ties
wonky it didn't match so the wind was
coming from the other direction oh but
the editor and a director looked at this
and said but that take he did we have to
use that one I mean it's just but
sometimes those things are so wonky like
if you think back to a famous one is
like pretty woman where she's holding a
waffle and then she's holding a pancake
kind of stuff where you go
I mean yes you want to go hey just look
at it but there's sometimes you go
that's a lot
that's a lot so I do find myself being
like I what I hate is I've watched so
many movies you read so many scripts you
know when you're in the business so long
you know you start to get like you watch
a show that's supposed to be a murder
mystery and then you find yourself going
I know who did it like it's that guy you
know it's like you know bigger you go oh
she's gonna be pregnant because it's
said you know like stories some
sometimes find themselves being the same
yeah so how do you let go of that when
you watch I'm just interested because I
you're so artsy I love this about you so
like you know you watch this obsession
and I can tell that you don't just enjoy
it that there's part of you that have to
analyze it like you want to be in it but
you can't find fault where you could do
something better you know it's like it's
easy to say oh I want to be a star yeah
but who would you play what cuz they're
doing a bad job because that's what you
love so that's always interesting as
well and you're like when you want to
jump in something because you can do it
better you just love something because
you're actually I used to cook Paul
Bettany poor better than me cuz I used
to watch him and just go it's better
than me he's that kind of dude can't do
a better job than him I love him that's
great right is there is there
did you always you always wanted to be
an actor obviously because you started
so young you this is like what your
career you've always wanted to do you
living your dream now I think I mean I
did start young young but not am I not
that not the kids do you get these kids
are starting it for ya yeah I didn't at
all it was not until I was about 16
really that I joined that's pretty
matter you theater yeah that's still
pretty young you know 16 for you to be
do this thing but you've lived you've
lived a full life I mean you have you
you started at 16 you have a 17 year old
yeah you know I mean like you know me
you don't even have gray in your beard
yet look at me I just this coronavirus
has got me like you know with this new
look and I usually don't have this but
now I can't go back from it cuz people
have seen it you know if I die it now
people don't understand that like we dye
our hair a lot of times because of a
part like they might say to you like I
don't even know you know they might say
to me like well we want you to be
younger looking so can you do that so
that's why I would do it but like just
living in life I mean I don't
my vein like I don't know if I'm vein
like that I'm doing that right now I
this every part of me wants to do the
coronavirus buzzcut I know I think I'll
do that and then I'll get a phone call
girl yeah they want you for bombed can I
wear a wig you know is that well yeah
that's what you mention that as a
British person a British actor is being
James Bond one of your goals I think
every British accent wants to be would
never play Bond and they would love to
play Bond everyone it's our only
superhero to be honest he did cast an
austere an American was born dead be
outraged yeah Captain America and I got
a recall and I did a good job in the
room and the casting director actually
said to me she won't mask your world I'm
Clive was great les was great and she
said the Joe Johnson's never gonna trust
a British Captain America yeah even he
was because he had already been like in
Fantastic Four yeah using all kinds of
stuff even though one of my favorite
roles for him is the snow pincer I don't
know if you saw that movie yeah and
there's no Pearce or whatever it is but
they're making a TV show out of that
actually you know they did there was a
TV show coming out about with from that
concept but yeah I think I would have
been outraged to have Captain America
was like British I must still have said
that Superman was Australian you know
you know what I mean it's like come on
yeah well I mean if there was an
American being James Bond I think that
there would be it would be outraged
right how dare you complain when all of
our superheroes are across the pond
it's really it's like come on you guys
the hypocrisy of it isn't if that if
like Vin Diesel was playing bond I would
be outraged I think we would be outraged
it would be a one minute silence oh man
but listen man I really appreciate you
being on the podcast we've talked for a
good enough time I don't know how long
we were gonna talk but I hope you
enjoyed the conversation and I do wish
you a best of luck I think that the show
is great I really I'm not just saying
that I watched it like I said I watched
it last night because I wanted to know
what I was gonna be talking about and I
can say my girl was just bawling and I
was just like oh this is one of these
shows it's gonna like it really got you
like you didn't think it was gonna get
you and it gets you and then you're just
mad you're like god damn it now I have
to like invest in these cuz for me when
I watch his show I don't watch a lot of
shows because I can't get into too many
relationships because this is a
relationship you know what I mean it
becomes like I gotta find out what's
going on with these people you know and
by the way speaking of that you know
with the coronavirus and everything
going on like I just wonder like winter
Productions gonna come back like how
long are we gonna have to wait for a
second season two's in like cliffhangers
and things like that well I think it's I
think there's a lot of shows on these
networks that they haven't got many
completed seasons right now seven or
eight 21-0 haven't got any more so we're
gonna say hello
listos are just gonna mid midseason
break like ten months until we figure
this out
I hope we do figure it out I mean cuz I
was gonna say do you one last question
no but I know I was trying to go but I
actually have another question for you
do you think that some shows like a show
like yours Council of dads do you think
they will incorporate the coronavirus in
the scripts where it's like a season of
like you know of what he called a
distant social distancing and Quarantine
II do you think do you think people want
to see that do you think though
I show like that can thrive in that
environment or you think it's gonna be
like we have to just ignore this and
it's not part of our universe um no I
think I think so I just think about the
day I actually thought we missed trick
if we just because at the end of season
one there is that kind of like this is a
big thing that happens and it's like we
all would
we've been ahead of the curve right but
yeah I mean it'd be interesting because
we don't what the thing is with causal
dance we don't really do flashbacks like
this is us those flashbacks we don't do
flashbacks that's what makes it
different so I don't see how we can go
back if it's you know next we start
season two with it and it's still going
on now we could do that but it wouldn't
be like with it would have to be like
remember that months when we again
otherwise we'd be inventing the future
which is not necessarily because it just
could happen again
it's just really weird it's just strange
times like I don't know I don't know
what's gonna go on with our business you
know that's the only thing that I fear
for myself is like my comedy business is
just shut down all the comedy clubs are
closed and all the live performances are
shut down and I wonder how we're gonna
get back to it like are we gonna see are
we gonna see like big scenes again in
movies where there's like you know a
hundred people in a restaurant is it
gonna be like yeah like how is it let's
say they're not dealing with the
coronavirus in the script but how are we
gonna deal with it in practical ways of
shooting shows now are there gonna be no
more big scenes like how are we gonna do
this as well as the cinemas is this
gonna be the death of cinema I love like
I never thought that Netflix or anything
like that was gonna take away from the
Moot that you can't you can't replace
that movie experience that big silver
screen and the apps name but this
emphasize the place designed to watch
movies on your phone I just think it's
just the devil incarnate I just yeah
yeah but you know what these things have
been around for so long and people still
go to the movie theater like like like I
always thought that like I would still
go watch a movie in the theater even if
I already watched it on my TV because
I'm like I want to go see it with the
Dolby sound with the you know the sounds
coming from here and like somebody's
sitting next to me and we're just like
oh this is
like I saw 1917 in a theater and it blew
my mind I loved that movie so much in
the experience of it and I hope we get
back to that too so I agree with you
100%
I don't know how we're gonna deal with
until there's a vaccine until is
anything I can't see how they're gonna
start getting these big budget things up
well there's hundreds of people because
even if you'll fill me in the desert in
the middle of nowhere and you're gonna
quarantine your actors and crew in the
same hotel and they eat and drink and
sleep in their own motel they go to the
desert with an honor to bump into anyone
it's most shows you're gonna be in a
city street somewhere with so many
variables you can't control but even but
even who wants to do that anyway you got
three kids I'm telling you like hey we
want you to do this thing for three
months and you can't be near your family
because we want to keep everybody
quarantine just to do that I just don't
see how you can insure it until that's
not the case I mean I finish those well
you're really really ill you're
literally like I can't get out of bed
and they're like can you come in they do
not care they're even like I've been on
situations where I've seen actors where
they're they're obviously sick and they
have to kiss another person and they
just go well we'll have some vitamins
you suffer from cold sores because you
have to kiss someone that's it you can't
so once you've got a co so you can't
film a love scene or anything until so
it's a serious thing always made me
laugh but I realize how serious it is
but by the way if I get this disease
that ridiculous physical we have to go
to where they're just like okay but if
they really that's all they care about
do you have a cold sores now they're
gonna be like I mean you mention all the
things they don't ask about that could
still be a problem just cold sores
now we're gonna be like coronavirus cold
sores so what but I hope it works out
but anyways man I'll let you get back to
your family this has been mr. Clive
Stan's that's how you say it again stand
in straight and stand in stand-in
fantastic British Britain's own on the
Council of dads and you can see them on
a bunch of other things too so you wrong
Vikings take in a bunch of great movies
I really appreciate you coming on and
anytime you have something to promote
you your your you have an open
invitation and I hope you have a great
rest of your day and I appreciate you
being on RIF and what Griffin man and
you thank you very much you take care
all right